the keian beauty contest what's that so
the keian beauty contest is this idea of
different levels of human interaction
with things so let's say you lined up a
hundred people and Chris has to go rank
them in order of who's the most
attractive that's like level one but
level two that's quite a simple idea but
level two is when you're also predicting
what everybody else in the room will
think and what's really interesting is
what Chris will rank is very different
to what he will think everybody else
will think and then level three is
another layer when you have to factor in
everybody else knowing that everybody
else is playing the game and what's
interesting is when they run these
experiments let's say they ask people to
rate the cutest dog video what they
think is the cutest versus what the
group then when they vote for the group
will be the cutest it completely becomes
different so when people are aware of
other people's perceptions it completely
shapes things so in terms of like a
practical application for this there was
a period where um the lib Dems were
voting higher and higher in the polls
almost up there with conservative and
labor so people were saying oh these
guys are great these guys are great but
then when it comes to that level two
thing well what is everybody else going
to vote for people don't actually vote
for them because they're factoring in
everybody else so when you're dealing
with thinking systems or other people
and predicting what they're going to do
the behavior becomes a lot more complex
as a result yeah there's a an
interesting study that was done
on
women giving their level of
Education when they know that other
people are going to see the answers and
when they think that it's going to be
kept private and female intersexual
competition says that women should
downplay their successes so that they
don't get sabotaged by potential other
females that are trying to uh dagate
them and manipulate them in some way or
another get that new tonic and you're go
on let's go get it down you um and what
it means is that
uh when women know that other people are
going to see uh that that other people
are going to see their answers they
downplay uh what it is that they've
achieved when they're keeping it private
they tend to be a little bit more
truthful uh but you know the abalene
Paradox you familiar with this oh mate
you're going to absolutely adore this so
ginda first introduced me to it right
and it's just again when you see it you
can't unsee it the abene Paradox is a
situation in which a group makes a
decision that is contrary to the desires
of the group's members because each
member assumes the others approve of it
it explains how a number of accurate
individuals can become idiots when they
get together so I think Emperor's New
Clothes in a way an acquaintance invites
you to his wedding despite not wanting
you there because he thinks you want to
attend you attend despite not wanting to
because you think he wants you there at
a business meeting someone suggests an
idea he thinks the others will like
perhaps recruiting a trans influencer is
the face of the brand each member has
misgivings about this but assumes the
others will think that they are
transphobic if they speak out so
everyone approves the idea despite no
one liking it or every member of a
family in North Korea who hates
communism but they never mention this to
each other because each each assumes
that the others approve of it you have
this or I've had this on social
occasions as well where you'll be at
dinner and it'll be getting later and
later and nobody's left yet and
sometimes I'll be sat there looking at
the clock am I going to leave I going to
leave and then one person leaves the
high agency exit it's a Mexican wave of
people exiting the whole thing exits and
what's beautiful about the Keynesian
beauty contest is it it deals with
reflexive systems where people's
perceptions shape reality and reality
shapes perceptions does this great so
George Soros um does this amazing
Financial Times article that he wrote
about
reflexivity and Talib said this on feris
I didn't know if you knew this that
Soros wanted to be a philosopher but
basically just had this Shadow career of
crashing the pound and becoming like one
of the biggest hedge fund managers in
there but one of his one of his ideas is
this concept of reflexivity which is
like so a statement
of the WEA is going to be rainy today
that's not reflexive because I'm dealing
with a natural phenomenon in the sense
that my thinking or my words doesn't
shape reality so if you said that on TV
it doesn't change to ever but if you go
on TV and go this is a revolutionary
moment the statement impacts reality so
you see these feedback loops between
perception reality thinking and reality
so you're dealing with human beings the
systems are so much more complex which
is why you see these meme stocks pump
and down because people are everybody
else is thinking the meme stock is going
to pump as well everyone is trying to
not only work out what they think about
a thing but future project what other
people will think about a thing and then
adapting their projection and trajectory
of the future to account for that yes
and then also thinking that other people
are thinking that about the overall
thing as well so that's how complex
things can become Robin Dunbar taught me
that the main reason in his opinion that
human beings brains got so big is not so
that we could more accurately remember
where the food is or use tools or fire
or or contemplate the higher Mysteries
it's because if you live in a 30 person
pod of 150 person tribe and I know
George and I know that George is friends
with Dean but Dean used to be friends
with George's ex-friend Josh and now
Dean and Josh so and and it's this very
complex intersecting web of hierarchies
and who's in and who's out and by how
much and who used to be like this so the
human brain largely is a uh like
Facebook friend tracker uh with knobs
and dials that you can keep a keep in
touch with and that's why he said that
human brains got so big because
computationally to try and do you know
this it's like you know one squared
versus 2 squ versus 3 squ versus four
squ the numbers just yeah run away with
each other and that's kind of how it
work it's like 30 squar it's like 30
people and each of their interactions
with each different person now and in
the past and in the future and what do
we think's going to
happen I think just yeah the idea of
reflexivity as a whole and then when you
see it you can't unsee it I don't know
if you ever done any cognitive
behavioral therapy but there's this most
simple model in there which when you go
ah okay this all makes sense now and
it's like the reflexivity of the human
mind where you have a triangle which is
how you think how you act how you feel
and all three of them impact one another
so how you feel impacts how you think
and act how you act impacts how you
think and feel and how you think impacts
how you feel and act and then when you
begin to see this triangle constantly
exist and I had the biggest midwit Mee
moment ever whilst I was away I was in
late Como perfect scenes and I was
driving this little speedboat I was like
like I'm [__] James Bond right now
like I'm living the dream right anyway I
see a video back and my face is
like I I said to the person who filmed
the video I go is this what my face is
like all the time they go yeah you never
really smile resting [__] F I had
resting [__] and I honestly think one
of the highest like Roi things of just
shaping perception is I me you told me
you have a tattoo of a smile there it's
a smile yeah and listening to the Sam
Harris podcast you did of checking in
the present moment and just rather than
focus on the breath just focus on how
your facial expressions are and just the
simple like it is the highest thing of
just moving it to a brief smile a your
perception completely changes but b as a
reflective system rather than people
going [__] hell that guy's really
serious it's like oh that guy's a bit
fun treat him as something else yeah I
uh I realized that I was socially
anxious especially toward the end of my
20s at the end of my teens and then
getting into the start of my 20s and
that's a reflexive recursive system as
well because if you're nervous around
people people might interpret that as
nervousness or as seriousness or
whatever which means that people treat
you in a manner Which is less warm
because you appear less warm which means
that you see the world as an adversary
not as a compatriot which means that you
then are less capable of opening up and
there it goes well that's it's the same
with the thinking feeling an acting
thing right so if for example you have
the thought I'm I'm a introvert and I
hate going out therefore you feel a bit
more wanting to stay in a bit down and
then you act like that and then that
cycle completely repeats itself and it's
so simple and it's why cognitive
behavioral therapy has such an impact
right when you can see that triangle
yeah and then go well which lever am I
going to gonna P I've told you uh my
theory about introversion most people
aren't introverts their friends just
suck that even around like if you get an
introvert around the right people
they're no longer introverted and it's a
recursive loop as far as I can see many
of the people that believe that they're
introverts are just in the wrong social
group one of the questions I was going
to ask you about is things you've
changed your mind on and on this
specific point I had that realization
where when covid happened a lot of
people experienced this where they start
going online and they're meeting so many
interesting people because the online
world you immediately go to like Global
maximum like the best of online and then
you can immediately think that I'm just
going to be online from now on I'm just
going to be doing Zoom calls over time
I'm going to be in telegram chats and my
online friends are so much more
interesting but the realization that
it's just because the get getting to
Global maximum or like the peak of the
internet you just log on and you're
there and you find your little tribe but
trying to find that in person is really
difficult but then when you find it it's
like a 100x corre better it's deeper one
of the interesting things that's
happened with the Internet is it's
allowed people with very Niche interests
to find other people that have got Niche
this is all of Reddit right Reddit is
refined not by individuals but by topics
and it makes it unique in some regards
right
for social media um that's been great
because people that are into obscure
late 80s anime from one particular
region of Japan or whatever are able to
get together and enjoy whatever it is
that they're into so good for a
selection effect but bad for depth right
and in person very difficult to find the
three other people in your
500,000 person City that's also into
this obscure anime but if you were to
find them the level of depth of of
connection which is why I think uh using
the internet to explore and then using
in person to exploit is the best
Paradigm that's how we met yes you know
we selected to become friends through
the internet and then once you do that
you go okay let's twist this into in
person what super strange about this
though is all you need is one inperson
event like if for example you never meet
and you use the digital layer as the
foundation so you just text chats video
calls you could stack like thousands of
them versus if you have one physical
experience that acts as like the the the
floor that you then stack everything
else on top of it's so much richer you
only need a few inperson meetings to
then be able to stack it's the reason
why I I put it in my um newsletter this
week I think it was uh always say yes to
dinner and if someone's coming through
town and you may be a little bit tired
and you just don't know whatever
whatever but you've been kind of a bit
interested in this person in a while
you've been chatting to them on the
Internet or something uh just say yes to
go to dinner and the number of times
that just saying yes to a meeting a
quick coffee with somebody a catchup or
whatever it is the number of friends
that you have on the Internet is so vast
and the number of people that you've met
in the real world is so small that if
you can be the sort of person who steps
out of Internet friend and into real
world friend which only takes 30 or 60
Minutes to you know Traverse that
particular CU if you were to just like
five someone in an airport as you're
both rushing for planes I don't think
that does it I think there needs to be a
little bit of cost there needs to be a
little bit of investment of time put in
run about 60 Minutes you know dinner a
dinner would be more than enough to be
able to get this done but if you can do
you know a trip with somebody if you can
go away with somebody or if you can go
through something a little bit more
difficult like uh taking mushrooms
whilst doing VR
um um then yeah you can you can get out
on the other side memes both of us are
massive fans of memes you're going to
meet Harrington a little bit later on
today who came up with meme first
explain
later before we even get into talking
about the most important memes that I
want to run through with you
why what is it about memes and
stickiness of ideas that's so important
why do you think that's so crucial to
get right so the first point is that
Meme itself the word is an ironic word
it's kind of like dyslexia like no
dyslexics can Spell dyslexia and the
word meme is itself quite a bad meme
because when you say meme to most people
what do they think they think of uh dog
photo dog photo on the internet so you
need to zoom out a little bit first and
go a meme is essentially just a
spreadable idea and how it the story
spreads from people to people so dog
photos is part of that but you have okay
Boomer you have Karen learn to code
learn to code make America great again
like all these things whether you hate
them love them whatever are memes and
they spread and you see this where
there's ideas that have
existed that haven't had the right meme
kind of like a product that hasn't had
the right marketing and then you create
a meme for it and like charisma's been
around for so long people have spoke
about it but it's always so nerdy IDE
Charisma was like the most uncharismatic
topic to talk about ironically Sorry
Charlie Hooper sorry um but all of a
sudden you create the word RZ and
everyone wants and then the language
shapes perception and then people are
actually talking more about it same with
the word ick like the fact that you then
have this placeholder to then discuss
these things but I think the fundamental
thing with a good meme is the almost
look at it like a simple algorithm and
thanks to covid like I I've known about
K factors for ages right or our numbers
it's essentially for let's say with Co
different strains how if I had it or one
person had it how many people they
spread it to so if you go over one then
it's exponential growth this is a big
thing in the startup and Tech space for
a while so when you're analyzing a
Facebook coming along how many when
Chris joins if he brings one more person
with him on average then just infinite
growth until until it disappears but
with a meme what you need for that K
factor is essentially the level of
emotion and the friction for it to
spread and how simple it is to
understand the more complex it is um the
the less the meme whereas when you
shorten it down to Riz and it's catchy
and it's three it's three letters all of
a
sudden is it could be it could be um
depends if you're north north or south
London um yeah I was talking to the dude
that founded legendary Foods the
cinnamon roll thing that I gave you
earlier on and I was saying to him what
do you call the category of products
that you've got there we've got a craft
everyone that's pointing in this
direction there's a craft table filled
with protein Goods over there and um
I was like what do you call what you do
and he's like we've been trying to uh
like nomenclature this for ages because
the closest thing is protein bar right
but it doesn't capture what's there
because there's crisps and there's a
cinnamon roll and there's a poptart and
there's like donuts and stuff so it's
not a protein bar a health snack a
protein conscious confectionary treat
like healthy sweet like what you know
and it's all about getting the meme
right yes and if you get the meme right
everything Downstream from that works um
the episode I did with Eric Weinstein he
made a really nice tweet about the fact
that he was talking about making the uh
the temporary archival I think or the
ephemeral archival and he likes the idea
of filming things in high quality
because he gives it more gravitas and
more Evergreen sort of Lindy nature but
he said to me over text uh in a
stickiness arms race great ideas don't
stick around because insufficiently
sticky so you can have an amazing idea
that's called protein bar but it needs a
better meme name yeah and you can do the
reverse as well which is what people are
very skeptical of which is this is a
cool sounding name product
category movement whatever but there's
no there there right it's just Meme and
no yeah all meme no substance yeah yeah
yeah once you see it you can't unsee it
and my I mean it's already happened so I
don't even think this is a crazy
prediction but you look at the 2024
election or insert future elections now
thanks to social media that will be
decided by who has the best memes not
who has the best policies and once you
see that you can't unsee it and I think
the the key thing to them factor in is
now you have global internet and the
next level you're kind of seeing it now
is Spotify two years from now maybe
we'll be speaking right now in
Portuguese because of this AI language
translation so you then factor in
language is no longer going to be a
barrier internet adoption is going to be
completely Global as like of the third
world fully hop online and the older
generation dies out the ability for a
meme to go from nothing to 24-Hour
infestation of the entire world like a
virus either positive and beautiful or
negative and destructive is uh is about
to happen I was talking to somebody
who his book title was a pun right which
is kind of like a meme like a play on
words it was like a a book about sex
called you're doing it wrong or
something like that right uh and he
mentioned that he was selling the
translation rights but because words
what you're doing with me with puns
specifically which is a kind of meme is
playing in uh multiple interpretations
of the same word or the same sentence
but by design that doesn't translate
over into other languages so his great
piece of advice was if you're going to
write a bck title that you intend to go
International don't use a pun because
you can end up like talking about the
flight of pigeons or something by
accident because they're trying to
retrofit your pun to this new language
which doesn't work which means that you
have to either compromise the pun
entirely or keep the pun but lose what
the actual context is well on that
specific point the to explain memes is
essentially to say people judge your
book by its cover the age-old advice of
don't judge your book by its cover is
because people judge the book by its
cover so if you can spread it they're
try they're trying to stop us from
enacting our nature so one meme that I
think is terrible that I think so
important for people to understand is
and we use me and you use this word a
lot like if you had to graph it in terms
of words we speak after like the and uh
and a few others water this one's up
there which is leverage like we use
leverage all the time and I originally
got it from n Val's book Almanac and I
when I heard it I almost didn't want to
admit I didn't fully understand it cuz I
didn't want to sound stupid so I'd go
and research it and I go okay so there
this guy called archimedian
and if you have enough leverage in
engineering you can create things where
the the input can produce a much greater
output so people will use it like that
so when I created a company I tried to
create the cultural value around
leverage right so I created this Google
sheet and everybody would input in there
like the highest leverage task that week
so that was one of the values that we
tried to create as a company and every
other value made sense but we'd go we'
go in there and we do these weekly
checking calls and everyone would be
like I'll be honest with you I don't
know what highest Leverage task means
and I was like huh and then you zoom out
right now you've got like the Instagram
gurus who chat about I'm the hardest
working man in the room and then you
have the kind of meme of smart work
versus hard work and none of it none of
it really sticks especially coming from
an educational system and then when you
begin to fully understand like code
leverage media leverage Capital leverage
labor leverage it begins to stick a
little bit more and I was thinking how
do you actually get this into an idea
that begins to translate one of the
terrible ideas that I do have for this
which I'll bring up because I it's it's
on here which is a lot of napkin maths
but is essentially I wanted to do this
as a kid story but I need to change the
name to begin with i animate it it's
called hung over Jeff Bezos on his
yacht right versus versus the world's
hardest working man so we have this
story of these two individuals competing
against each other cuz I identify with
the world's hard hardest working man I
grew up watching Eric Thomas videos of
like You' got to want it us better does
you want to breath like that kind of
stuff and ultimately so let's say for
example we give this Instagram guy who
talks about hardwork this guy is better
than everybody else cuz he doesn't sleep
he works 24 hours a day right Jeff woken
up at like
11:50 like nagging headache he's
probably got one of the best vitamin IV
drips in the world goes on his jet ski
that day probably does a zoom call with
his chess coach like whatever who's
worked harder that day if you judge it
in the old fashioned interpretation that
I think a lot of us have that don't
understand leverage because we don't get
engineering and things like that you go
well he's worked 24 hours that day
Jeff's done a few slack messages but I
was like trying to go well what if you
actually ran the napkin math so right
now if you looked at it as purely as
like outputs so this guy's got 24
outputs of hours of manual work that
he's been doing whereas Jeff's been sat
on his ass if you look it like that
that's Z 2 24 to zero but all of a
sudden when you begin to quantify
leverage you go ah this begins to click
a little bit so this is napkin mask from
about a year ago so the point of napkin
mass is not to be in the comment section
saying that this is wrong I know some of
these numbers are wrong but just it's
for the metaphor so Jeff has 1.6 million
people that work for Amazon so let's say
they all work eight hours per day Jeff's
achieved 20.8 million hours of work that
day then if you looked at robot leverage
so Amazon's Warehouse when I looked at
these statistics has 500,000 roaming
Factory robots AWS has 1 8 million
servers they all work 24/7 for him
that's 55 million hours of robot work
per day whilst he's been sat on that
yacht and I'm not even going to get into
how much more output a robot can achieve
per hour than if you let's just give the
hardest working guy that that he can
keep up with them okay then you look at
advertising leverage Amazon spends $46
million per day on marketing assuming
assuming it costs him $20 to reach 1,000
people um he's receiving 2 .3 billion
Impressions per day hardest working guy
is going around knocking on doors right
trying to sell his product so so Jeff's
advertising Leverage is about the
equivalent of doing 95 million hours of
door knocking per day then you look at
medial leverage so twitch gets 71
million hours of content viewed every
day Amazon Prime has 117 million
subscribers let's assume that the 10%
watch one hour per day that's 11 million
hours of content viewed every single day
so that's 82 million hours of
Storytelling done in person that this
guy would have to do so and then let's
not go into all the other things you
could think of related to Amazon so
hardest working guy in the rooms worked
24 hours Jeff sat on his yacht with a
hangover and watching bits of succession
and zooming away has achieved 244
million hours of output and then when
you view it like that the whole leverage
complexity the the reason why Leverage
is a bad meme is because you need other
topics and other realizations from
engineering to understand it which
prevents it from spreading but when you
go
oh hung over Jeff Bezos on his yard
versus hardest working man in the world
you realize that in the 21st century
despite probably the PTSD from the
education system Leverage is more
important but it's a [__] meme in other
news this episode is brought to you by
cozy Earth we sleep onethird of Our
Lives do not spend 33% of your life in
anything other than unbeatably
comfortable sheets getting a good
night's sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer and the sheets that you have are
massive determinant of just how
comfortable you feel cozy Earth has the
most premium bedding and loungewear that
I've ever found they're made from super
soft Visos from highly sustainable
bamboo temperature regulating so you
will sleep comfortably all year round
and an enhanced weave quality that won't
pel so it's higher quality will last
longer and you will have a more
comfortable night's sleep and wake up
feeling more rested and revitalized plus
there is a 10year warranty on all of
their products that's how confident they
are that they're going to last but don't
just take my word for it Oprah has
chosen cozy Earth as one of her favorite
things for 5 years in a row now you can
get an exclusive 35% discount sitewide
on everything by going to Cozy earth.com
slod wisdom and using the code modern
wisdom 35 a checkout cozy earth.com
wisdom and modern wisdom a checkout Shan
Puri has this idea about what you work
on is way more important than how hard
you work and he says hard work is very
overrated uh and he's I think he refers
to himself active refers to himself as
like a successful lazy man uh and he
optimizes for laziness and frictionless
and um yeah it's the same you know the
janitor or some guy that's working
double or triple
shifts that amount of effort doesn't
have an in-kind return to them compared
with somebody who is able to leverage
code or Media or labor or capital or
even just picking the same amount of
input that they've got with very limited
leverage but on a better task a task
that has more potential upside long term
the the key thing is to remove the
conversation around hours work that we
had from school and just be inputs
outputs so I have this number of inputs
what number of outputs am I getting and
remove the concept of ours work remove
everything else and all of a sudden that
Meme is a little bit stickier whether
that's going to be a a kid story or not
probably not I need to adapt the title a
bit but I think to view view leverage
through that makes it an easier idea for
people to understand but the reason why
Leverage is a bad meme is because people
don't have the engineering knowledge it
doesn't spread which is why it's such a
Silicon Valley concept and I think this
idea still hasn't fully rippled through
Society don't forget as well that
exponentials and squares aren't
something that the human brain is built
to work out it's like that um I want one
square of one piece of rice on the first
square of the chessboard and two pieces
of rice on the second square of the
chessboard all the way up and by the
time you get to the final Square on the
chessboard you've got more pieces of
rice than there are [__] particles in
the universe or something we just don't
deal well with exponentials which means
that leverage inherently given that it's
dealing with um unfair
multiplicativity system rather than an
additive system for the most part it's
this times this not this plus this uh
it's just going to be tough to
understand you've got a an idea the best
memes compress Mass emotion into a
simple contagious concept like okay
Boomer or Karen what's that mean well
first off look at okay Boomer who
doesn't understand that two words Karen
who doesn't understand that make America
great again who doesn't understand that
you can hate those memes but it's
compressed so much emotion so let's say
the okay Boomer one it's compressed so
much emotion of the millennial and gen
Zed being spoken down to by the boomer
generation who have messed up a lot and
it's completely compressed all that down
and boom that spreads same with Karen
same with even the word make America
great again like there's so much emotion
way more than it's for Words yes it's
way more than the constituent Parts yes
yes yes and with memes it's all it's I
forgot who said it it's the idea of I'm
sorry I didn't write you a shorter
letter but I didn't have time yes so the
people look at it and go oh that's so
unfair I wrote this 10,000w essay that
nobody ever read but versus this meme
has spread but you need to be able to
optimize for that K Factor but you need
to be able to compress as much emotion
into that word for it to sprad did the
meme industrial complex used to be the
purview of mainstream media were they
ever creating memes effectively or is
this a internet thing again it's it's a
little bit reflexive in the sense that
they both interact right so what rup
Murdoch would put on the news would be
because he kind of knew what people
would like and then what people liked
was kind of because what they saw on the
news and there's this constant thing
here so rupop Murdo or that generation
of the meme industrial complex that
owned everything and could control the
narrative I actually think it's ironic
that they've made succession now because
they wouldn't have been able to make it
10 years ago because he had so much
power right versus now it's like we can
do what we want it would it would have
seemed more like a documentary than a
drama and you can see why the mainstream
media dislikes social media so much
because the mainstream media had the
meme industrial complex in that they
could put ideas out there and control
the narrative whereas now the meme
Industrial Lex is essentially this
bottom down approach of complete
decentralized meritocracy to some extent
yeah it's all the users rather than The
Gatekeepers that are creating and a few
algorithm developers who nobody these
faceless algorithm
developers a little bit there and comp
and go you know what on YouTube now we
actually prefer long form podcasts in
the algorithm boom and that just
completely shifts things so it's weird
how you've got these kind of faceless
algorithm creators now and these face
craters that own the meme industrial
complex the last memes most of the memes
that you see that come out of mainstream
media are accidental memes so it's a a
guy trying to propose to his wife a
baseball game or something that gets
wiped out by a security guard or
something it's not it's never something
that is designed to be funny it's always
the byproduct of something that was
supposed to be something else which has
come through in that way I've also got
this idea about how if you want to be
able to predict the future look at a
current cultural movement or meme that
hasn't had the inverse already made so
um 2020 Co gets released that summer
everyone has to stay in the house 2021
Megan the stallion starts talking about
hot girl summer last year you weren't
able to be free and liberated therefore
this year uh you can be your best self
you Glam up go out with the girls sleep
with the guy Etc 2022 is feral girl
summer which is you know treat yourself
like an animal don't watch wash don't
shave just put baggy clothes on and and
and don't take any care of yourself um
another version pickup Artistry uh comes
out sort of late 20s early 2010s then
you get that sanitized by me too which
is a counterculture movement in some
regards not just to that but to other
stuff then you have red pill then very
quickly you have mtow and black pill
that comes out of it so if you want to
predict the future of memes look at a
meme that's been created that hasn't had
its inverse M uh come out too because
every movement needs its counter
movement in order to be able to balance
it because there is a market there is a
meme market for anything which is not
the thing which is currently popular for
every movement there will always be it's
like the equal and opposite Force thing
for every meme there is an equal and
opposite meme that comes out well
question for you is what do you think is
you know we had the chat last time of
what is ignored by the media but will be
studied by historians and what we're
kind of saying there is what's a really
important topic that hasn't had its full
meme moment yet right yeah and what do
you think bars what do you think are
super important topics that just haven't
like haven't been me correctly that's a
really really haven't caught on yet or
will catch on like what ideas sound
crazy today but five 10 years from now
I'll be like oh yeah that's the thing
yeah I think
[Music]
um a lot of individual personalities uh
so this this seems to be a very
effective way to get memes to move you
know like the M the of the sigma male uh
which is kind of the guy who steps
outside of the of the hierarchy I don't
think that there's very many uh good
memes for women I don't think that
there's been many like archetypes most
of them are like derogatory in a lot of
ways so like you know like the Karen the
party girl the like Dubai yach chick um
there's not many there that I think are
are like almost aspirational in a way
and maybe this speaks to female
personality and disposition that they
don't have you know I don't know about
girls but guys would happily have like
He-Man or the rock or whatever on a
bedroom post to wall but girls would
also a lot of the time have guys like
some hot uh singer I don't know whether
uh girls use role models and
aspirational admirable figures like if
you went into a teenage girl's bedroom
and had a post of Jordan Peterson quotes
on the wall you'd think like let take
you off to psychotherapy um so uh yeah
certainly individuals in some ways like
memes for uh irational memes for girls I
think that there's a massive market for
them um what about
you this is I think one of the most
important topics but it's so ugly and
boring and I I even like I'm fearsome of
saying this because I can just feel
people like skipping to the next YouTube
chapter as soon as I say this but give
me like a minute to just say it and it s
even the word now right you're going to
go right cyber crime right it's just
like nobody takes it seriously but it's
so [__] important and just to maybe
give a bit of a story that's going to
help with this have you heard of the
Bangladeshi bank heist no now we're
talking right this is g to blow your
mind and again it doesn't sound good
right now but it's going to be good so
the biggest bank robbery in history was
I think it's about $60 million in Brazil
in about 2015 2016 with cyber crime
recently they almost hacked $1 billion
from the Bangladeshi Bank using the
Swift system right for context that year
the Bangladeshi GDP was like 230 billion
so think with GDP as well it's movement
of money it's not total money if Chris
sends George 10 and I send it back boom
bo boom that acts towards the GDP but
it's just us exchanging money so imagine
taking $1 billion dollar like that from
a developing country immediately um and
the only reason that fail the only
reason this isn't there will be I I
think five within 5 to 10 years there
will be a covid like moment you remember
pandemics before covid it was like bird
flu swine flu you just be like oh the
sun's just trying to get clicks and
things like that I remember I used to
tell people about Co in January February
I won't say who but they used to call me
conspiracy George for bringing up covid
and now obviously pandemics are taken
very seriously but there will be a 911
or a covid like moment for cyber where
things get very very dark very fast I
think the Bangladeshi bank heist is only
a tiny example of that where you go from
60 million robbery in person to 1
billion overnight and the you know the
only reason why it failed is because the
hackers that were working on this system
so they emailed they sent an email with
a CV application the person at the bank
clicks on the CV infects everything yeah
they're working on it for a year they
time it perfectly during the New Year's
holidays everything about this height
has gone perfect bear in mind this bank
would only move about 300K around the
Swift system so it goes to the Federal
Reserve in America says sees 1 billion
and they're like yeah sure so it's like
the the security systems weren't in
place the only reason it failed is cuz
two two things one they had a typo for
the addresses so literally it didn't
fail because of the amount it failed
because of human error human error like
and it was a really basic English
spelling that they made a mistake and
then two the bank in the Philippines
they were sending it to was called
Jupiter Street and Jupiter was a company
associated with Iranian money laundering
so it just happened to flag in the
system otherwise it would have gone
through both of which were human a
billion would have been taken from
Bangladesh like one of the poorest
countries in the world like that and the
impact that has and you then begin to
realize what happens at one point when
certain airlines get attacked certain
banking systems get attacked and we're
so but because I say the word cyber
security and only 3% of the audience
have carried on right now so boring but
we need we need stronger memes around it
because it's such an important topic
yeah wasn't it uh you told me some story
about the
salary that was yes offered for for the
British head of cyber security so the
head of cyber security in the UK we
spoke about this last time got offered a
salary or like on link in jobs it was 55
to 65k pounds for the UK uh 7,000 80,000
yeah which listen is obviously a great
income for most of the world but for the
head of cyber security when you're
dealing with hackers that are trying to
steal $1 billion dolls
yeah yeah it's just evidently something
but it's that's specifically I'm going
to guess a uh governmental problem
because I'm going to presume the head of
cyber security at Facebook is paid an
ungodly amount of money because they are
already red pilled on just how big of a
deal this
ish but if Facebook goes down it's
obviously a big issue but if Government
systems go down a lot worse if the
emotion caused by the meme is greater
than the friction of spreading it you've
cracked the meme algorithm it's exactly
that that that is an example of a simple
but not easy truth that is all memes
does the emotion outweigh the friction
of spreading it if so you've created
that positive one number that it begins
to spread Spread spread Spread spread
it's so simple you've got one in here
that's the same as mine the easiest way
to predict the next meme is to look at
the current memes and bet on counter
memes appearing you take that from me
you better have done potentially it was
my idea the fastest growing companies in
the next 10 years will have a chief meme
officer working for them directly or
indirectly I like if you look at all
these fast growing consumer businesses
they are they either have a chief meme
officer in house so you can think of
these influencer celebrities that are
cre a McGregor with proper 12 the
McGregor Meme and all the kind of sub
memes that he creates around him who the
[__] is that guy etc etc then product
there or they'll have memes working bu
through them indirectly that they'll
ride on so like we was chatting about
marck health this isn't a plug but um
you obviously your testosterone numbers
going through the roof and people
huberman the huberman meme people
chatting about optimization and I guess
they do have Derek running it but still
riding that Meme movement yeah if they
would have done it five to 10 years from
10 years ago it probably wouldn't the
Imp that it's happening but now Chief
meme officer indirectly or directly boom
yeah it's I think the I learned about
this word you're glowing you taught me
about that a while ago Zach taught me
about it and then Mark w't show up about
it as well you know what that is like
when someone looks like a federal plant
and they're putting across information
that is to um persuade the populace but
people can see through the fact that
they're actually doing it on behalf of
the CIA ex CIA agent says that CIA isn't
actually listening to your phone calls
mate you're glowing right like that's
that's that's the sort of [__] that
they'll say um but I think people are
skeptical now even of memes perfect
perfect perfect example did you see what
Jim shark did with Francis and ganu
where he broke that door switch it out
get the get the orange boy in there come
on um you see where Francis and ganu uh
broke a door no right
so Jim
shark like fed a video onto Reddit that
they created of CCTV of a person that
was supposed to Francis and garu didn't
turn out to be him uh breaking the door
of a corner shop the glass door that
wased yes right and they staged it
created it used a stunt double instead
of Francis for the bit wether glass
brakes put Francis back in had him get
shouted at by this fake shopkeeper in a
fake shop front uh fed it using a burner
account onto Reddit and then from Reddit
it got picked up by Twitter and then
from Twitter it got picked up and Signal
boosted and some people saw through it
like this looks like a cuz he's wearing
gym shark this looks like a a plant from
gym shark or whatever whatever but for
the most part made headlines papers
picked up on it all the rest of it so
yeah the how would you say the like
contrived meme complex or the
manipulated meme complex like the
MMC uh is something that everyone's
skeptical about you know I look at each
platform now like a meme information
Highway and each one produces different
memes just due to the constraints of it
so the memes that get produced from Tik
Tok are quite unique and correct yeah
they don't export particularly well yeah
whereas people that come out of YouTube
like yourself slightly different um
what's interesting though is most memes
that get created you go back and it's
Reddit it's fourchan maybe bits of
Twitter and it goes down the meme
information highways and then ends up at
LinkedIn I wonder all roads lead to lead
to Boomer Facebook yeah WhatsApp message
from parents yeah um I wonder whether
one of the reasons that forchan and uh
Reddit work particularly well is are
written memes the most robust of
all because you can turn something
that's works on written into video into
spoken but the reverse isn't necessarily
true like there was that one of the dude
drinking was he drinking like ocean
fresh cranberry juice whilst
skateboarding down the street listening
to Le Zeppelin or something it's like
some song from some band and then this
song's now number one across the world
because this one dude skateboarded while
drinking cranberry juice or something
[__] sales of cranberry juice went
through the roof and he's now the
Ambassador for [__] ocean fresh or
something um that doesn't necessarily
translate across onto written word but
most written word memes can be
translated across and do get used
potentially but I think another factor
to so it's you have you heard the l
lapal loser effect it's why you stack
multiple multiple biases so on that
specific point I think you've got that
but it's not just that it's also the
fact that most people on there are
pseudonymous and Anonymous which means
they can just see the Overton window
here and go I'm through I'm going to go
through here and then ultimately it's
the memes that shift the Overton window
with time but the ability for them to be
pseudonymous and Anonymous and then
create something that they can they can
go into territories that right now the
the meme industrial complex won't touch
and then they push it through I had this
idea about how um there is a lot of
derogation of mainstream media at the
moment you know like mainstream media is
dying and uh no one really cares about
it anymore and it's all about
Independent Media and it's all about
YouTube and podcasts and stuff like that
but what you do forget is that there is
still quite a lot of status associated
with going on mainstream media because
it's a scarce resource yeah right there
is an unlimited number of YouTube videos
that everybody can upload there's no
status or Prestige associated with
uploading a YouTube video getting lots
of subscribers or getting lots of plays
or having lots of followers on Tik to or
whatever but anyone that's got an iPhone
can work Twitter or work Tik Tok or work
YouTube but there's
only 200 Dr Phil guests per year right
so because it's inherently a scarce
resource there is
still uh value and Prestige associated
with it because of the selection effect
oh you've had to be pre-selected it's
like the [__] Hunger Games right so I
think that something that's probably not
been priced in is first the that General
uh scarce resource Prestige associated
with still associated with mainstream
media because it's a limited resource
and secondly uh the huge swath of Boomer
parents and people who aren't
chronically online who see Dr Phil you
know all of Middle America you know that
whole daytime TV thing the loose women
thing like they still move culture they
just don't move culture in a way that we
care about at the moment um there's this
really interesting just a side point
this really interesting uh is it Liberty
Mutual of someone it's this Bank in
America and they're playing it really
well it's like um uh we can't stop you
from becoming your parents but we might
be able to help you invest and save and
all of the adverts are about like um
younger people than should be
complaining about these particular
problems complaining about problems that
are beyond their age like someone who's
um parking over like two parking spaces
and they're like shaking their fist kind
of like their parents would do what
someone that's cutting the Hedge too
early in the morning or something like
complaining about things their parents
might have once complained about but
they're too young for it and the point
is like you're going to grow into
complaining about the complaints that
your parents have got so let's say it's
Liberty Mutual or something they're
using the meme of okay Boomer as almost
self-deprecating for us all to Future
project ourselves out into that uh but
yeah mainstream media scarce resource
what do you
think again I think there's a little bit
of a lolip pooa that exists as well in
the sense yeah it's a scarce resource it
still has a shadow of its former self
like even if I see a seven-year old
boxer I know who that guy used to be and
he can still even if even if he's like I
could beat him up now he still has that
shadow of his former self so I think
it's that it's when I did the Fox News
thing for the Kalin cocaine phone which
followed like the most serious news
stories that it was me in Amsterdam with
sliders on my feet and like a Blazer
here chatting about that yeah and that
even though it probably got way less
views than this or anything else that
I've done was treated so differently
because of the fact it was mainstream
media pres yeah there's this um an idea
called conceptual inertia which is that
it takes a long time for ideas to change
even if the science does uh I spoke to
this um he's like a a science historian
and he was talking about the development
of um science and then belief over time
so for instance when you get the uh is
it like the geocentric as opposed to the
heliocentric view of the solar system
that it's not the Earth that's at the
center it's the sun that's at the center
and
um when that happened even though it was
after a while first off it was heretical
then it was exploratory then it was
proven but tons and tons of the populace
just hadn't come along for the ride
ideas die one generation at a time and
it takes a good chunk of time for people
to catch up and it's kind of the same
with mainstream media right not only are
there still people around that hold
mainstream media like even I do to some
degree you see some person on [__]
Dancing with the Stars and you're like
oh well done for that person even if I
wouldn't want to do it um so not only is
there still people around that are
living that but also even once they're
gone the echo of what they valued is
still valued and it takes a little bit
of time for this stuff to go away how on
that point though of ideas die one
generation at a time how do you is there
any way to speed that
up as we're because because technolog is
changing so much faster and faster right
now an idea is
Holocaust but like how do you deal with
like gpt3 gbt 4 and people being able to
catch up with I don't think there's I
don't think that there's a solution for
it mate I think that humans run at the
speed that they run at I think you can
overclock humans in the same way that
you can overclock technology you're just
playing this game and we're going to
move along uh and and what you end up
with if you try and do too quickly is
you end up with fire hosing which
is the problem of overloading people
with information isn't that they start
to believe one narrative increasingly
more frequently they begin to distrust
all narratives overall because they just
can't get but first it was this thing
and then it's this thing Co everybody
during almost everybody during covid
almost everybody during the last
election almost everybody during the
[__] Israel Hamas War which we're not
talking about like that is it's this
thing and and no it's not it's actually
this thing it wasn't them that did it
and then actually yeah it is those and
no it's not your tactic your story was
wrong and what people end up doing is
just saying all right I check out so the
answer I've had for this
is if you look at something like David
Deutsch's beginning of infinity which I
think is an amazing idea but the meme is
tough the problem that exists is and we
spoke about this before where five years
ago you cringe at your former self but
the what would have probably have sped
that up maybe doing five months rather
than five years to realize those
mistakes was thinking five years from
now I'm going to cringe at former me
what are those things yes so there's
almost this simple expression I
developed which is like everything is
wrong is the first bit of it and you
just assume every belief that I hold is
wrong everything George and Chris has
said to some extent is wrong anything
that defies the laws of physics is wrong
and will be we will look back at it 5 to
10 years Lo opinions loosely held yeah
but the problem with that is it just
opens up this Vortex of like where do I
like the what do I do yeah the floor's
gone like you're just in this spinning
infinite Rick and Morty Loop and you
don't you don't know what is what and
people would prefer to have strong
beliefs than just complete nihilism and
complete everything's wrong so the
conclusion I have with that is that
everything's wrong but there are better
or worse ideas so constantly looking at
okay so I've got this new idea in my
head it can have a placeholder there and
I I like it and it was better than the
previous idea that I had and then you're
constantly playing this infinite game of
stacking up knowledge and stacking up
knowledge but always realizing cuz what
will happen is you'll get the new idea
and then you think that idea is right
how how many times have me and you
developed some new morning routine
become completely addicted to it and
being like this is it this is the answer
I found the answer and then a couple of
months later we got it wasn't the answer
the Lindy effect works so far well with
that if if a person sends you about this
new app new meditation habit new XYZ
morning you been doing it once you've
been doing it for six months let's check
in because then it's serious Thiago
Forte uh the reason that he doesn't use
anything other than Evernote is he
refuses to use software that's not 10
years older or old or older it's like it
has to have been around for 10 years and
it's basically the exact same as what
you're talking about there Lis Perry
taught me yesterday this great quote uh
tradition are the experiments that
worked
H yeah that's the thing that yeah the
thing that people are often defending
was once the replacing thing yes yes yes
yes yes because unless it's been around
for [__] forever like and how many
things are axiomatically just like
unmovable or unmoving from when it first
ever happened what's this Trojan horses
to avoid thing so he having a uh phone
call with a good friend of mine and his
business is he's doing very very well
and he says to me he goes I've stopped
listening to all business podcasts I was
like hold on I like your business is
doing really really well and you but
you've also stopped like consuming new
information about business he goes yeah
I just watched NFL stuff I'm like huh I
I I getting mid wited meme right here
and I was like why is that he goes well
the problem was particularly like the
stuff that isn't just like Lindy
business content like new ideas this
this industry is popping off he would
just get shiny object syndrome yeah and
the critique of that like
self-improvement space of how can you
watch football or how can you do that is
the problem with him with the business
podcast is that it was like Trojan
content or pck porn like a pck victory
it was a Trojan content in the sense
that he felt it was good for him but it
was actually harming him and I'd say
that is often a lot worse than the
things that you know are going to harm
you so I if you eat a takeaway and you
know it's bad for you I think that's not
you account for it the next day yeah
that's not as bad as thinking
something's healthy a trojan horse
getting in and it's actually really bad
for you how was the business podcasts
just dig into how they were Trojan
horses a bit more well in the sense that
he has a business that's working really
well and he just has to exploit and
focus and work hard whereas when they're
then going oh there's this new AI thing
that's popping off and people are
getting funding here or this guy's
exited his business for ABC and he's
been doing it half the time so he'd just
get envious he'd get shiny object
syndrome versus just putting on the
football he's like switch the brain off
know what I need to do and you can see
these Trojan horses that exist
everywhere so like you could have I I
call it like a Trojan pay rise where you
kind of get this incredible job that not
not incredible job or job I had this
happen to me where a job comes along
enough as you double the salary but you
stop learning as a result and on the one
hand yeah you've got this thing that
feels like you've made progress but
actually on a long enough time Horizon
it's going to massively reduce your
potential because you're no longer
learning so looking at these Trojan
horses everywhere a long commute would
probably be one of those um you we've
been talking a lot about uh hidden and
observable metric and a really great
observable metric is salary and a really
great hidden one is commute length uh
you know know the dation of your energy
to do things when you get home the
quality of your relationships and your
friendships the amount of time that you
have to be able to learn new things and
yeah you can trade in your ability to
upgrade yourself for a better salary but
you're right over a long enough time
Horizon what was it that was going to
give you more happiness or satisfaction
or even salary in the end it was
presumably going to be your skills and
the rapidity of you to be able to
upgrade them so yeah I that's very
interesting have you noticed in your
life any uh Trojan horses that you've
let sneak
in I I'd say certain bits of content I
find I'm a lot more specific with like
my information diet now so even stuff of
I trying I used to try and keep on top
of the world's cutting events and then
I'm because I felt like I needed to be a
responsible Citizen and I needed to be
on top of things and I realized that a
the current thing would just disappear
there's this constant new current thing
that will then disappear two months ago
parel calls it the was it the Perpetual
now yeah and by the time by the time
it's on Twitter it's like the peak stock
price it's you know what I mean by the
time it's everybody it's the B it's as
big as it's going to get so avoiding um
constantly keeping on top of all the
world's in constant which I used to
think like I was being an informed
citizen because people would use the
term I wrote about this people would use
the term ignorance is bliss and I go you
know you're in this like Nichi and
upside down Society where people are
using Bliss as a shaming mechanism cuz I
think we like I I realized this where
it's something like I think there's like
500 million tweets uploaded per day
there's 500 hours of content uploaded to
YouTube per minute and I think something
like 67 million people die per year
right so we're all in the ignorance
gutter but it's like some of us will be
looking at the stars and I think you
have to be so specific with that
information di because by definite you
can cannot consume all the world's
information it's why I used to have my
you know this I used to have my Twitter
trending topics to Angola so I just keep
up to date with like the Ang so
basically on Twitter you'd have the
trending topics in your region and it
would be like I'd get distracted by all
these complex issues and I just feel
like [__] afterwards it's like Trojan
content yeah so I just updated it to
Angola and know Angola now unfortunately
for me because it's it's done it the way
that as you're as you've realized you
can't hack it with Angola I'm still in
the UK based on um Twitter which means
that at least twice a week at the moment
Chris Williamson Trends Chris Williamson
MP of course the unfortunately named
Labor uh I think it's darbishire that
he's a part of uh very anti-semitic
which means given the current
geopolitical climate it's a bad time to
be a Chris Williamson at the moment but
I always used to think whether or not uh
he would look and see his name trending
but it not be him and think like what's
my love Island Ultra ego done this time
[__] hell he's gone on another
reality TV show I've got I'm doing this
live show with James Smith in Dubai in a
couple of months time next month
actually uh and I wondered given what
Chris Williamson has been talking about
his very you know like Pro Middle
Eastern uh talking points whether
there's going to be a a huge welcome
party for me as I step off the plane at
dxb airport and how disappointed they
will be when this Chris Williams strides
off the plane yeah reality so far has
just been an SEO Warfare between you two
and everybody else watching this is just
NPCs in the simulation that is that do
you ever watch the one with Jet Lee that
film no uh it's like he in this other
Universe he's able to move between like
350 universes or whatever and there's a
version of you in each of them and if
you kill yourself the power of all of
you gets shared between you so this guy
tries to become the one this evil jet Le
goes around killing all of the other jet
Lees in all of the other different
universes and that's kind of the SEO
battle between me and Chris Williamson
darbishire MP at the moment [__] it out
on the uh looping back round because I
was be an infinite Vortex there with the
information diet hack I recommend and
people think this takes way longer than
it is but I do warn people that you will
stare deeply into the abyss and the
abyss deeply back into you YouTube they
should remove this but YouTube has this
Buton where you can see your history and
I I went through I clicked on it and I
was like I just go through the last 100
videos that I watched it takes like five
minutes to do and I just ranked them in
terms of regret neutral and like glad I
watch that and 72% of the content I
watched I booket it under
recret so that's an example of Trojan
content well the post content Clarity
thing was an idea that I came up with uh
to try and help me it's exactly that
just like less statistical
um while you're watching something it's
almost always compelling even if it's
[__] for you and making you feel
worse because if it wasn't compelling
you would be watching something that was
it's like the meme uh evolution of the
Mr Beast countdown to the 1 billion doll
yacht that he's going to spend time on
or whatever right like that's the most
compelling piece of content so even
stuff that you don't like is compelling
in the moment or else you would have
switched and watched something more
compelling but it's only after the it's
like a post kital pillow talk with
yourself after after you've done a
session on YouTube where you get to say
okay and how did that stuff make me feel
like do I want to ring my friends do I
want to go outside do I feel like the
world is against me or for me um do I
feel like I can go and Achieve things do
I feel more educated more wise more in
tune with myself or do I feel the
opposite and a lot of the time I think
the things that you watch are limic
hijacking and compelling but the after
effect like the come down the content
come down is so so strong that uh if you
were able to Future project yourself
forward and realize what's the hangover
that I'm going to get or the content
come down I'm going to get from this the
post content Clarity um yeah the pillow
talk that you have with yourself
actually would remind you that it's not
worth it and YouTube actually is a a
platform for this is kind of useful
because there's a few options you can
put in um don't recommend channel uh if
you just see something on your home
screen you can just press the three but
three dots and say don't recommend
Channel and you'll never see that
channel again unless you search for it
right it'll never just randomly appear
on your feed which is phenomenal uh so I
think that's you know if you were
talking about crafting and shaping the
information landscape that we're a part
of and it's all esoteric and [__]
like philos philosophical and stuff but
from a tactical perspective like that's
one thing um if people use Twitter on
desktop which I do I don't have the app
on my phone I very rarely use it on my
phone um
tweex uh which may now be called tweee
um is a way that you can see the most
popular tweets from people but it's a
Google Chrome extension that when you're
on your home screen it actually sits
over the top of the trending news so
it'll hide trending news so you can't
put yourself in Angola well you can but
it doesn't work but you can use tweex or
tweepy uh and the Google Chrome
extension will hide that and replace it
with like top tweets from one of the
people that you follow I think we've
probably got about 5 years left of this
algorithmic Warfare of trying to get you
to stay on platform as long as POS
because as soon as more and more AI
tools come on and then you begin to have
these Dynamic conversations of how you
want to feel based off these algorithms
I think we'll look back at this as a
very very weird time in history when
most content was created by humans as
opposed to robots no in the sense that
that to some extent but more importantly
like for example you see the difference
when you go from YouTube to YouTube
premium and you can skip certain things
and you can download things why can't I
just customize my algorithm more why
can't I have a kale algorithm during the
week and then a cocaine algorithm on
Saturday night versus this kind of
static algorithm because the problem
with the algorithms I actually realized
when I was doing that YouTube audit the
best the YouTube is amazing when you use
it for search and it's such a high
agency thing there where you're sitting
there thinking and going oh okay I want
to learn about X or I want to do ABC and
you search it versus the explore page
when it's just fun mely solo agency
because by definition it's trained on
your past data so it's keeping you stuck
in the past whereas when you're actually
searching on YouTube for topics you
you're actually breaking out of the past
and creating a new data set that's TR
there's multiple use so I've realized
this Uber does this very well actually
um where at different times of the day I
take different Journeys so if it's first
thing in the morning it'll know that I
tend to want to go to the gym uh if it's
the middle of the day there's a couple
of restaurants that I typically go to uh
if it's on a a
Wednesday at this time it knows that I
usually go and get an appointment at
this place or it's a haircut or it's a
whatever and it knows that I go from
certain places to other places very well
done right but that's because there's
multiple use at multiple periods of the
day YouTube hasn't yet realized that I
only watch long form documentaries about
like the in-depth trench warfare
strategies of World War I on an evening
time like at night to fall asleep so I
like listen to like some Ken Burns
documentary or like some long or
whatever like some 11 part uh
psychoanalysis of Hitler that I'm me
balls deep in at the moment right um
that only happens on an evening time but
it means that it resurfaces it to me
during the day so yeah there's multiple
U's at multiple times and you know like
you can go from dark mode to light mode
it's like do I want to go from learning
mode to entertainment mode but I I don't
think that that that doesn't seem to be
likely just because what the platforms
always want you to be in is click on
mode right they don't want you to have
agency over what it is they just want
maximized time on site let Outsource it
to don't forget especially YouTube that
algo is a black box if you were to go to
YouTube the engineers and say tell us
what you're doing show us the algorithm
they're like yeah what do you think we
know you think we know what our
algorithm does we set it like
two [__] uh reward functions like
time on site click through that's it and
then just let it run it's just this
recursive nightmare where everyone
descends towards UFC knockout
compilations all the way down the stack
yeah yeah H what's the forgetting
Paradox so thanks to your Sam Harris
podcast I started going more and more
down a mindfulness Rabbit Hole bunch of
people did that I was with someone
recently that said that it's so good and
within that he has this few things that
I had out the back of it that then
created the forgetting Paradox which
which is you start to observe your
thoughts and Sam presents this idea of
like think of a candle and he goes well
are you that candle it's like well no of
course I'm not that candle so it's like
why do you therefore identify of every
other thought and then he has this
scenario where it's like think of or
basically wait for the next thought to
appear in your head and try and predict
it as it's happen or like just try and
observe it as it's happening sorry my
one was so is so Niche this my one was
so I sat there and from nowhere this is
when I realized I wasn't control my own
thoughts it was just iron Robin cutting
in on the left wing he's like this
former football player who retired like
8 years ago and I'm like that it's
almost like a dream state and I was like
that's why I called it waking uput wrers
that's fantastic yeah and the thing that
I hadn't heard Sam talk about that I
realized off the back of that was ask
you I'll ask you this question now how
many thoughts like clear sentence
thoughts do you remember from yesterday
very few almost none can you think of
any like a
sentence one over dinner that I spoke to
Alex about who's debating Ben Shapiro
today but I didn't say it to him okay
because he was talking so you remember
one thought from yesterday what about
the day before I assume day before zero
right yeah I so so you have 10,000 to
70,000 thoughts per day and you captured
one anyone listening at home pause it
and just go how many thoughts do I
remember from yet like clear sentences
not I feel hungry or whatever clear
sentences so from a 24-hour window kind
of like Twitter or Tik Tok the mind's
thoughts completely disappear and it's
quite a useful tool that then when a
thought Loop appears you just go oh this
is going to disappear tomorrow and you
realize the forgetting Paradox is this
is not just at the individual
psychological level it's at the general
societal level of we
forget how many things we forget because
by definition we've forgotten them and
if we hadn't have forgotten them
therefore we would have remembered them
the same way you had 10 to 70,000
thoughts yesterday and you remember one
but you don't remember you don't even
realize how many thoughts you forgot
because by definition you completely
forgot them and you see this with like
trending topics as well where it comes
and then someone will mention that and
you'll go [__] I I haven't thought about
that in years it's only when the that
pops back in do you see the forgetting
Paradox that guy cutting back in on the
left wing yeah yeah yeah well you're
very good at this it's one thing I've
changed my mind upon as a result of this
like there's a probably a whole wave of
guys that listen to your podcast who are
like just ghost in Instagram guys they
don't really post the social media but
one of the uh second and third all the
consequences of that is you don't
capture much of your life yeah and I'm
stting here now at 29 I've always
avoided photos and videos because I
didn't want to be seen as that vain guy
on Instagram yeah but I think something
you're very good at is capturing content
and as I get older you realize how
important that is because you go [__]
but you decoupled I realized this too
that coming from like whatever a [__]
I come from a love Island background um
which is um the problem of that that is
I Associated taking photos with posting
on social media and being go right I did
lunch on Sunday from the plane uh with
Douglas Murray in this nice [__]
restaurant somewhere I had Crocs on uh
and Douglas was in a full suit and we
had lunch and we it was four hours and
we got to have this great conversation
and I was like I want to remember this
not that I don't not that I would forget
it in any case but I want to properly
remember this but you're like when do
you take a oh mate come here let's take
a photo
hang on a this will when that resurfaces
on my memories or whatever I'm not
taking aot to it on social media but
because most people only take photos so
that they can then post them on social
media I dissociated taking photos and
remembering my life with being a vain
Instagram idiot not the same we need to
like make photos great again for guys
yeah like decouple taking photos from
thinking that you are creating content
right or being narcissistic or doing
this to to cor and that's even worse if
you're a content creator right if you're
someone that's posting stuff on the
internet you're like oh here we go again
like better [__] switch the workface
on whatever it's not like that it's like
I'm just taking a photo to be with my
friends but I wonder about how
uh how much people think about the the
focus
on the thoughts that arise how much they
they
consider what they're going through
right now to be unbelievably important
you forget how many things you've
forgotten because you've forgotten how
much you forgot this has always been a
justification for me to get people to
force thoughts into words either spoken
written even art in some regards but I
think it's best to do it in actual words
because I've said this a million times
on the show but when you have a thought
it's like a cloud right it's like trying
to hold smoke it's like this wispy
ephemeral kind of like it's a smell it's
like this Ambiance that you've got and
you're like it's yeah I kind of know
what it is it's okay tell me like tell
me what that idea is and then you try
and squeeze it down into words and you
go I actually don't have any idea about
this and I remember before I had the
podcast I but after I'd started thinking
about things more seriously but before I
had an outlet that caused me to be
rigorous and highly scrutin uh
scrutinize heavily what I was thinking
about I had ideas that I didn't know I
had ideas that I didn't know right this
sense but I'd never forced it into to
take form and it concretizes thing
that's why writing is such a good tactic
for this or or having conversations with
people that you care about you know the
strategy of um recording a podcast with
a friend that you're never going to
publish like 30 minutes once per week
put the voice recorder on if you don't
want to be a content creator or you just
can't be bothered or you're not
confident enough yet sit down with a
friend press record have a conversation
about whatever you want but it's focused
it's rigorous so on well there's a few
things here so one there's this idea I
store from baji which I call it the BAGI
Transformer which is when you wanting to
become creative he tries to understand
everything from a written perspective
then from a algorith like he'll create
an algorithm of the same piece then
he'll speak it out loud then he'll draw
it on a whiteboard like Walt Disney's
business plan map and the when you
transform it from thought to words to
written to visual drawing you actually
that action of transforming is where the
creativity begins to occur or the
clarity
um on this specific point
though I think relating to the
forgetting Paradox that begins to exist
as a result is or we we've particularly
going back looping back round to CBT
that we spoke about at the beginning
this is like such midwit simple [__] but
it's so good like we talk spoke about
the the CBT triangle at the beginning
the next thing that they get you to do
is so let's say you have like a
recurring thought of I'm a [__] loser
like something really dark the natural
thing like the Instagram gurus are like
no you believe in your like pump your
chest up so in CBT what they'll what
they'll get you to do is we just write
down the thought that you have and the
ability to move it from mind to paper
and you just kind of look at it there
and then the next thing which is great
what they do is rather than just like
try and fight that thought which then
kind of creates balloons it more and
more and more because you're repressing
it it's like what's five like bits of
evidence that support that it's like
well I'm losing Touch of all my friends
I've not been to the gym in weeks I I I
thought I'd be here by 25 or 35 and I'm
not there and you write down all those
reasons and then you go you get all the
[__] air out of the balloon of that
thought and then in CBT it just goes
okay and what's all the evidence that
you haven't considered it's like well
well when I go to XYZ party people are
so happy see me or and then at the end
kind of like the jury the for and
against you just go well based off all
the evidence I have now what's some more
useful potential for on this specific
point Have you heard of true uh it's
from Derek civas which is so good which
is this idea of um not true but
useful yeah I've been playing with
something similar which is figuratively
true but literally false and literally
true but figuratively false yeah whereas
we had that chat about determinism right
whereas I think determinism is
potentially true but harmful and good
what I realized now for the determinism
debate just say I'm I completely agree
with you guys unfortunately I'm just a
100% determined to believe Free Will is
true yeah and I'm just it's just
determined it's I can't change it um but
a good example that civas has there is
yeah useful or sorry not true but useful
beliefs and essentially anything outside
of physical reality to some extent can
fall in that of it might not be true but
what's useful and with cognitive
behavioral therapy you can just analyze
both for and against and then come to
your own conclusion yeah the
figuratively true but literally false
literally true but figuratively false is
great so um porcupines can throw their
quills literally false figuratively good
to stay clear of the [__] porcupine
um religion throughout time looked at
pigs uh as uniquely sort of morally
dirty animals uh literally false but
figuratively their flesh does carry a
higher pathogen load typically than
other animals like for like so let's not
eat them good the reverse
literally true true but figuratively
false or functionally useless would be a
different way to put it belief that uh
Free Will doesn't exist okay right
everyone seems to say all the smart
people seem to say that that's the case
and all of the people that seem to have
some counterargument to it it's all like
lexical Brazilian jiu-jitsu where they
actually change what free will means
like Dan dennet kind of does this he
just sort of kicks the can down the road
all of the like compatibilism stuff
seems to kind of Kick the Can down the
road but I spiraled a ex Club manager
into a two we depression because I sent
him 45 minutes of Sam Harris on Joe
Rogan redpilling him about Free Will and
he didn't leave the house for two weeks
cuz he's like well I've got no free will
it's [__] pointless right that's
[__] information Hazard I don't need
to know about that I definitely don't
need to believe it and I don't need put
any stock in believing it so
it I guess it's a bit of a slippery
slope if the only things that you
believe are functionally the things that
are beneficial to you because you can
end up actually no because useful useful
is the word not beneficial useful
because self deluding yourself to
something that's so grandstanding and
harmful isn't useful it's anything
that's fundamentally useful to you and
the people around you what's the new
ideas that sound crazy but will be
normal 10 to 20 years from now yeah so
obviously last time we had the what is
ignored by the media but will be studied
by historians and what ideas sound crazy
today but we'll be we'll look back and
go oh [__] kind of like when you know
the internet comes along and it's like
like everyone was mocking it and boom
we're here
now I have a a list of these so one
which is my greatest meme I've ever
created so going back to cyber that it's
kind of an ugly
industry one industry that might be
uglier than cyber there's two so one is
Plumbing industry and as a result
there's so many entrepreneurs creating
woot bands aura rings like trackers
glucose it's super sexy creating a smart
toilet like a the total addressable
Market is huge yeah if you have a smart
toilet and the meme I created was like
the toilet speaking to you which is like
good news you're hydrated bad news
you've got
chlamidia right and a smart toilet could
feasibly eradicate all STI and STDs like
that you could the amount of data that's
in piss and [__] yeah that exists but
nobody wants to touch that because it's
a bit bit icky right the same when uh
another similar strand to this which I
don't like to say out loud but we're
going to have to so m g porn company
that own every single porn site you can
think of had the biggest Technological
monopoly of all time but nobody spoke
about it there was no government bodies
getting involved because they didn't
want to touch it because it was icky and
I think a lot of these ideas are
potentially icky another one I think
about is with AI coming along right now
all my single friends complain dating
apps that they hate the swiping they
like the dates but they hate the swiping
and when dating apps came along it was
it was seen as the ickiest thing people
people mocked it but now like is like
50% of people meet their potential
partner online and the everything else
has gone through the floor in terms of
how they meet the only one that's gone
up is restaurants and bars have you seen
this so the only one that goes up in
that chart of how did you meet outside
of dating gaps because dating gaps is at
the whole market like Mark Andre
software reading the world is
restaurants and bars and I'm convinced
that's [__] I'm convinced it's
people who met on dating apps that don't
want to say that they met on dating apps
because there's a huge bracket of those
so dating apps at the whole market and I
think with AI coming along it's going to
be so obvious where where it moves to a
more matchmaking model where you're not
swiping based off your data sets and
then you're getting a few specific
candidates keeper. a no uh I'm pretty
sure that this is like algo Matchmaker
It's a combination of I
think personal uh individual actual
functional human and AI matchmaking
keeper it's for people who want
long-term relationships and uh yeah
they're trying to use data sets to find
compatibility between
people it makes sense right it's like
the anti-dating app dating app versus
manually swiping and judging it purely
off looks and then you meet them and
it's completely different and they don't
look that way and they've lied and it's
a completely broken
system yeah it's looking at what will be
accepted as a
plausible future technology I certainly
don't think I know that you've been on
this for a while you were you were
pretty sure that pseudonymity on the
internet would become more widely
accepted I still don't think that that's
going to be the case where' you sit on
that now I've got a weird opinion on
this one I could be so man all these op
because all your other opinions have
been so normal so normal so far uh all
of these opinions I think will
ultimately there's high risk in that
right if it a lot of them allow it to
fail because by definition if they sound
weird today it's because they're [__]
weird or they're wrong right but I do
think as soon as these you're already
seeing these virtual influence come
along and I think you'll have the pity
combined with a virtual influencer
because if you look at
traditional media reality TV was really
late only came along in like the 90s
like as it came along versus social
media it's always been reality TV
there's no James Bond in social media
there's no Spider-Man in social media
there's no Superman there's no Batman of
these characters with IP that begin to
exist so I do think that's where that
there's a guy we spoke about him called
the cultural tutor on Twitter and he's
just
gone um so I I do think that's got
potential but yeah I don't think it's
necessarily as big the pseudonymity
thing hasn't taken off yet but is that
because it won't take off yet or because
it's had certain technological
restrictions um I'd say the other one
which you you red pilled me on this so
me and you are on a flight like three
years ago this is inside the actor
studio and Chris's like this is bear in
mind Chris's podcast at that point we're
on a beach after that flight and he goes
if I can get things to 100,000
subscribers I think I'll be happy um and
you say to me on that flight or we got
our face masks on you go I'm thinking of
working with a speaking coach and I was
like as a friend I was like do I say
something here because I don't think
this is the right move and in my defense
I was concerned that you'd go the full
politician it would sterilize any
character I had when politicians speak
like this and it just immediately is
Horseshoe Theory like you you're so
charismatic it becomes uncharismatic and
I was concerned that would happen to you
and I told you that and you you
rightfully ignored me and then like
three years later I'm listening to that
Rogan podcast and he said that the way
you pronounced words if you was running
for president he would uh vote for you
right and I texted you going one I'm
sorry I was wrong two can I get an intro
right wanted an intro to the speech
coach so I do wonder whether Charisma
will become the new fitness so the same
way Instagram made people concerned more
about how they look voice memos podcasts
recorded Zoom calls remote work people
hearing themselves back will begin to
become a bigger bigger thing yeah that's
a that's a very good point we're
definitely being more surveillance
scrutinizes your delivery right in a way
that you didn't do previously
um have we seen people take writing
classes so they can do better Facebook
statuses I'm not sure um but no but even
like going back to what we said earlier
of RZ becoming a meme and then people at
least just thinking about yeah whether
there'll be more like doing exactly what
you did probably not but there'll be I I
think it'll become an area that people
are a lot more mindful of the same way
people who work out aren't necessarily
paying for a PT yeah that's true the Gap
in the gain was something I think I
introduced you to as well this idea that
there are two ways to live either
comparing yourself to where you want to
be or comparing yourself to where you
were and one of them is like running
toward the Horizon which is every step
that you move forward you are inevitably
going to push the desires that you have
one step further away from yourself
Morgan housel his quote about
the best way to win the game is to stop
moving the [__] goal posts uh and I
had this conversation with big Dan
belerian over the weekend and
said
um every time that you achieve something
what you're doing is positing a new
minimum bar which you have to get over
right fantastic I've just done this many
plays or made this piece of art that's
sold for a particular amount of money or
whatever how exciting and almost
immediately mediately there is this sort
of like postal [__] realization that
oh my God that's the new bar for my best
performance that's really high that
means I now need to be even better at my
next thing and someone recently won the
largest lottery in history A1 billion
Lottery someone just won that from a
life trajectory perspective that's
potentially one of the most disastrous
things that you could have happen to you
because how are you ever going to have a
better day than the day you woke up and
found out that you'd won a billion
dollars it's the argument is uh slow
success strategy would be to
purposefully try and drag out the wins
that you have so or Buffet sty a
tactical way that you could do this
would actually be let's say that you um
start to accumulate more wealth
Financial Freedom and stuff like that
and you can afford your absolute dream
car but instead of buying the absolute
dream car you buy one of the dream cars
that's kind of on route to that one it
was the the 50% or the 75% car that goes
in between because you'll still take a
good bit of pleasure from that one and
you'll have something to look forward to
that you know is within your control and
you're not then looking for the
overclocked 150% dream car right I mean
the hel I'm buying yachts and I'm buying
boats and all this other stuff so I
think and I said this to Dan you know
somebody who you know winning um poke
games and stuff is large influxes of
cash uh in kind of out of nowhere and he
seemed to agree that um it expedites
your ability to just like play the honic
adaptation game but it overclocks the
pace at which you have access to it and
it's dangerous so yeah slow success
strategy as a counter to the Gap in the
gain sort of game that we play with each
other and this whole honic adaptation
thing
h i don't it's one of those things
though of theory then reality like can
you actually slow yourself down once
that dopamine kicks in that takes a lot
of wisdom right it takes a hell of a lot
of restraint yeah I I mean I don't I
don't know and like what are you going
to do like say oh no I don't want that
billion dollars from the lottery please
sir but you know even with that okay can
I get someone to set up some sort of
fund or trust that like drip feeds this
to me or invests it in a particular way
or I I don't know just placing trying to
place your self worth in different
different ways
different different Loc
but I I I mean the Gap in the gain is
one of the most important ideas that I
keep forgetting about it's like a Ben
Hardy bck from three years ago and he
came on the show to talk about and it's
really great every time that I find
myself getting too deep into dopamine
Chris uh we should talk about that we
should talk about the difference between
dopamine George and serotonin George and
then also probably cortisol George as
well um but we both feel this and I
think a lot of people do that you just
live in this sort of
next task next achievement overclocked
hustle grind culture I will get my
pleasure from my accomplishments as
opposed to the one that actually ends up
being more fulfilling which is I spend
time with my friends lying in the park
under a tree like eating some snacks
that somebody brought along or something
like that's the more serotonin side of
things I think the Gap in the game is
just a better meme for abundance and
scarcity mindset abundance and scarcity
kind of Got Hijacked a little bit by a
lot of woo woo whereas beautiful thing
about the Gap in the gain so you always
have three things right you have who you
are now this [__] future idealized
projected version where you've
trillionaire and everything's going well
and everybody loves you that Gap no
matter again no matter how much you move
up just grows it's infinite versus you
have a third state which is where you
started so the the gain is measuring
yourself constantly from where you
started and the Gap is measuring
yourself to this infinite ideal but the
be to honest with you it's a nice
concept right but that's one of those
it's the forgetting Paradox you can
learn that and then it disappears for
two years from now but going back to
like resting serious face or resting
smile face the beautiful thing about the
gap of the gain is you can only you can
only exist in one of the two states at
once that's what I loved about that
concept is you're even in the gap or
you're even in the gain so just
constantly throughout the day either
resting serious face or resting smile
face yeah it's a simple razor it's mid
it's midwit which is beautiful yeah what
do you think's the most useful emotional
state
oh yeah so this is a a niche thought
experiment but I'll give it to the
audience
so the inspiration for this thought
experiment was you ever heard that kind
of bro bar debate of you have the
world's best athletes across every 100
top sports which one is the technical
best athlete in the sense that you take
a basketball player footballer NFL MMA
and they'd all do the other 99 Sports
who would rank the highest and there's a
big like bro debate about it it's great
and uh um I was like okay that's an
interesting idea and I realized I'd lay
there in bed and again I and Robins just
cro like cutting on the left wig and
then this thought Pops in my head and
I'm like what would be the if you
applied that for emotions what would be
the most useful emotional state so you
create this [__] Olympics of like
happiness s sadness anger Joy fear Envy
etc etc and then you looked at hundred
different life events you could be in
doing a podcast with you going for a
bike ride getting a Starbucks getting
fired from my job what's the outcome
that you're optimizing for here most
useful what's useful
H
probably achieving the outcome that you
would would have liked upon reflection
right okay is the way I'd probably
describe that um but i' I'd probably
need to think about that more but let's
say you have all those situations from
married to funeral to losing job to
first day at job and you had looked at
all the different emotions you could
have like which one would perform the
best on average and I realized I go
probably calm
if you could like it's not even like the
sports debate where it's like Up For
Debate I go I think carness just is top
for pretty much the moreall or if not
it's it's in the Champions League place
it's in that like top four and to but
then I was like okay let's steal my
myself here I wasn't sleeping that night
so I was like okay well let's say for
example there's a fire breaks out the
building would you want to be calm would
be the criticism of it and it's like you
wouldn't want to be slothful you
wouldn't want to be lazy but you'd
probably want to be calm I assume I'm
not a fan we have [__] jobs right
like we don't do serious jobs but when
you chat to people who have proper jobs
the best guys are the ones that are calm
Under Pressure so I think it kills that
and then the second criticism if you was
to steal Manet as well would be well
let's say it's your that may work for
neutral events or toxic events or things
where it has to go well but let's say
it's your wedding day do you want to be
calm and I was like that's probably a
good criticism but then I was thinking
about it and whenever you speak to
people about the wedding day they always
say it was great but I just wish I
soaked it in more I wish I could slow
down time a bit more and I don't think
anything slows down time quite like
calmness and for any criticism you do
have where you wouldn't want to be calm
the beautiful thing about calmness is
you can calmness is such a base state
that you can then ramp up any emotion on
top of but you can't do the reverse it's
really hard to go from an anger to like
Peak calmness yeah so I just looked at
it and go that wins the debate and then
I fell to sleep that night calmly yeah
calmly Douglas asked me yesterday what
like I aim for in life and I used the
word peace
uh which sounds so cooked like in
retrospect it just sounds so lame
especially when I'm talking to this you
know like Firebrand [__] like
cultural commentator guy like says
things that people don't like and all
the rest of it but it is true that like
if the price is your
sanity you shouldn't pay it for pretty
much whatever it is there's almost
nothing that's worth that because
ultimately without your sanity you can't
enjoy any of the things that you're
going to get from it in any case uh and
I think that largely calmness and peace
could probably be interchangeable here
but to to critique us here what I would
say as a listener it's like yeah that's
[__] nice and I might forget that as
part of the forgetting Paradox but like
what does that do it's like well how do
I become calm and the answer is I
haven't [__] fully figured that out
yet but i s I guess the first step is
realizing that it's probably the most
useful something to aim for and again
using the hidden and observable metrics
Matrix like it's one of the most hidden
metrics right the texture of your own
mind I will happily work a job with a
boss that's a dick that pays more money
that makes me feel miserable that causes
me to be anxious before I go into work
because I can't
see the price that I'm paying in terms
of my lack of peace or calmness right
but I can see the increase in my bank
balance every month right just trading
it in trading in that hidden metric for
an observable one you're seeing that
with glucose monitors in the sense that
people would just eat whatever yeah and
now they have that
orange juice and then video game
dashboard go terrible that they can
begin to piece that together we
unfortunately don't I was going back to
resting [__] smile face if there was
a way of tracking that throughout the
day and you could turn it into a video
game of where your facial expressions
were sat I think you'd have a lot
happier people it's weird yeah what was
that you told me and you described it
really beautifully and it was the first
time that anyone had described the same
psychosis that I go through when I
meditating about uh I'm the sort of
person that has thoughts about thoughts
oh yeah we were chatting about this over
dinner
where it it's this infinite Loop that
can exist when you're observing your own
mind and you get to a state of no
thoughts and then after you've dealt
with all the iron Robin thoughts the
what comes up is oh look at me having no
thoughts I'm [__] great and then you
end up in that well yeah it's a Trojan
thought you think oh wow I'm the sort of
narcissist that thinks wow look at me
the sort of person that has no thoughts
and then you think oh my God I'm so
self-deprecating I'm I'm the sort of
person that mocks me for being the sort
of person that thinks wow I'm the sort
of person oh my God and then you
just cycle of Doom so funny man so funny
what else you got um we always have
chats about uh High agency and again
that's a powerful meme right now but
I've been like collecting like examples
one of them that came from uh mutual
friend David CRA have you heard about
James Cameron I like this is one of the
craziest stories ever again talk about
memes or ideas so you know James Cameron
the movie director so he was a truck
driver when he was 18 and he couldn't
AFF form he couldn't afford to go to
movie St uh to a movie uh education what
you call it Film Studio film school and
he decided I can't afford it so I mean
the low AG thing that is like okay it's
set reality blah blah blah and I was
like this guy's so good that he came up
with the idea of going to the library
and everybody who could afford the film
degree when they're handing in their
dissertation all their work they' put it
in the library that night he would just
go there take the pieces late at night
put them in the photocopying machine
photocopy photocopy photocopy and taught
himself his whole film degree from
scratch because he couldn't afford it I
was like that is Elite story so good wow
that is
cool there's a another one we spoke
about a while ago in the high agency
Library I told you about the guy that
took down Silk Road so Silk Road was the
biggest black Market illegal drugs
Empire the FBI were after him the CIA
were after him the da were after him
this guy called dread pirate Roberts who
turned out to be Ross alri and there's a
lot about that case that gets super
political and I don't want to have that
conversation because I'm not educated on
it but the specific part that I found
fascinating
was the way he got caught so the FBI
with all their resources best Intel best
spyware in the world couldn't catch him
it was this one tax inspector who
started working on the casee and this
guy just thinks okay I'll go on Google
and just searches he goes what about if
I just find the first original post
about Silk Road online and he finds it
in this Bitcoin forum and what the dread
pirate robberts did obviously when
you're at that zero to one stage of a
new company even if it's an illegal drug
Market Empire you need to get people in
so he create an account like going oh my
God have people seen this and he's like
this is the earliest post that exists
online and he reached out to the Forum
owners I was like essentially reverse
engineered this Altoid handle what the
email address was and it was Ross
@gmail.com and he was the first guy to W
mask and I love that story because it's
like one guy with Google has beat the
FBI the CIA the daa achieving
essentially the most wanted man in
America at the time that's like similar
to James Cameron right like a guy with
essentially no resources but can
massively overperform have you watch
speaking of movies there's a new guy
Richie film out uh that's an oddly very
similar plot to the gentleman but is
different I can't remember what it's
called it's on Amazon Prime everyone
should go and watch it it's guy Richie
the guy's [__] brilliant but if you
seen it turns out Douglas is friends
with him and um you know that he has
created his own like Hut SL barbecue slf
footwarmer thing do you know about this
no right so in the gentleman if you see
uh Hugh Grant toward the end when he's
confronting Charlie hunen uh and trying
to screw him over uh the outside and
they kind of sat under this like kind of
a nice sort of indoor outdoor mezzanin
looking shed type thing and there's like
a fire and a big smoke turns out that
guy Richie invented that like it's his
product right this is the ultimate
product placement that he's put in and I
think they talk about one of the
features that he has in the gentleman
and then in this most recent one again
it's Hugh Grand playing a very similar
sort of role this time he's like a rich
billionaire like super super dick Guy
and um he's like cuts to this scene and
he's explaining how he's like reverse
searing a steak on guy Richie's custom
designed thing which you can go and buy
it's super expensive I think but you can
go and buy it on the internet search
like guy Richie barbecue and I'm sure
it'll come up and um yeah he just he's
just got this product that he's created
I'm pretty sure when he went on Rogan
that he talked about it but yeah he's
just got this product that he created
that is now featuring
in multi-million dollar blockbuster
movies in directed by this great guy but
yeah ultimately he just like a I guess
part of the funnel for his Super Chief
meme officer Chief meme officer yeah is
super expensive but barbecue what have
you got coming up next what's the next
few months got in store for you a few
different things uh I've got a few
essays I want to publish a few different
ideas I'm working
on but yeah just I don't actually know
how to answer that question just
enjoying it good where should people go
they want to keep up to date with your
reading your writing all the rest of the
stuff yeah so best place is Twitter or X
just George Cormac sign up to the
newsletter list as well at george.com or
George dm.com some bastard's got the
thing without the dash yeah you can find
it all there hell yeah George I
appreciate you thank you man thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode with George you will love
my fulllength 2hour Long podcast episode
with Douglas Murray go
on give it a watch